the people of africa cannot be blamed  for the immorally low level of  vaccinations available to them  nor should they be collectively punished  for identifying and sharing crucial  science with the world  so  [Music]  doctor foreign  justify imposing a travel ban on  countries that have zero case of the  umikon you know  that's a very good question an important  question and we did struggle with that  but we wanted to see if we could buy  time temporarily  when we have now these uh virus  everywhere  what is inacceptable is to have one part  of the world  that is one of the most vulnerable parts  of the world economy  condemned to a lockout  we have the instruments to have safe  travel let's use those instruments to  avoid this kind of  allow me to say  travel appetite  you